Unlike the Z and T tests, the distribution of the F-statistics is not
symmetrical. The F distribution is positively skewed, meaning it peaks on the
left side and is stretched off to the right side. This distribution peaks at 1.
This is because if there are no differences in the population means, in other
words the between group variability is. Expected to be 0. Then the mean of each
sample will still, likely differ by chance. Since the difference, then, is due
to chance. The same way that each subject in each sample differs by chance, as
measured by the within-group variability. Then the between group variability
and within group variability will be the same. Therefore, when we divide them
we get 1. And that's where this distribution peaks. Also note that when we're
doing an F test, this will always be non-directional. Whereas when we were
doing the Z and T test, our alternative hypothesis could have been that one
population mean is less than another. With the F test, we only know if there's
a significant difference. Our critical region will always be out here in the
upper tail. But everything else is essentially the same. We choose an alpha
level, usually 0.05. And then we find out if our F-statistic lies in the
critical region or not. If it lies in the critical region, we know that at
least two population means will be significantly different.